FOCUS" AND GO INTO
"OUTNUMBERED" FOR TODAY.
THE TOP REPUBLICAN ON THE HOUSE
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE ACCUSING
THE TREASURY DEPARTMENT OF
RUNNING COVER FOR THE BIDEN
FAMILY AND THIS IS COMING AFTER
HIS REQUEST TO LOOK INTO
REPORTS INVOLVING FIRST SON
HUNTER BIDEN WERE REJECTED.
>> CREATED FOR CONGRESS TO HAVE
ACCESS TO BE ABLE TO TRACK ANY
TYPE OF FOREIGN TRANSACTIONS
THAT WOULD LEAD TO TERRORIST
ACTIVITY.
SO THIS IS ANOTHER COVER-UP IN
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION TO
BLOCK REPUBLICAN OVERSIGHT AND
REPUBLICAN INVESTIGATIONS OF
HUNTER BIDEN'S SHADY BUSINESS
DEALINGS.
>> Harris: PETE HEGSETH IS WITH
ME CO-HOST OF "FOX & FRIENDS"
WEEKEND TO DISCUSS HIS FIRST
REACTION TO THIS.
>> IT'S NOT SURPRISING.
FIRST OF ALL HERE IS WHAT WE DO
KNOW.
THESE ARE SUSPICIOUS ACTIVITY
REPORTS THAT THE TREASURY
DEPARTMENT TRACKS.
FROM WHAT WE UNDERSTAND FROM
THE RANKING MEMBER OF JAMES
COMER THERE ARE OVER 150 OF
THEM THAT COULD PERTAIN TO
HUNTER BIDEN.
SUSPICIOUS ACTIVITY REPORTS OF
OVERSEAS DEALINGS.
TRADITIONALLY CONGRESS HAS
ACCESS TO THOSE REPORTS FOR
OVERSIGHT REASONS.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION JUST
ABOUT A YEAR AGO CHANGED THE
WAY THE EXECUTIVE WAS WILLING
TO COMPLY WITH THE HOUSE SO NOW
IT REQUIRES BEING IN THE
MAJORITY TO GET ACCESS TO ANY
OF THOSE REPORTS.
OF COURSE THE DEMOCRAT MAJORITY
IS NOT INTERESTED IN LOOKING
INTO SUSPICIOUS ACTIVITY.
JAMES COMER IS TRYING TO GET
HIS HANDS ON THEM AND IT WILL
PROBABLY TAKE A NOVEMBER
NOVEMBER ELECTION FOR HIM TO DO
SO.
>> Harris: I KNEW ABOUT THE 150
AND ALWAYS WONDERED IF YOU HAVE
THAT MANY REASONS TO LOOK AT
SOMEONE, YOU WILL TAKE A LOOK
AT THAT PERSON.
WHY CAN'T WE KNOW WHAT THEY
WERE SEEING?
BUT ARE YOU SAYING NOW THAT THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IN
ADDITION TO ALL THE SWITCH
FLIPPING THEY DID AT THE
BEGINNING OF BIDEN'S PRESIDENCY
ON THE BORDER, WHEREVER IT WAS.
HE WAS FLIPPING TRUMP'S
POLICIES, RIGHT?
ARE YOU TRYING TO SAY HE HAD
TIME TO CONCENTRATE ON CHANGING
THIS AND THAT IT BENEFITED HIS
SON?
>> IT'S AMAZING HOW MANY LINES
THERE ARE IN THIS FROM WHO
REPRESENTS HUNTER BIDEN AND WHO
WENT TO THE F.B.I. AND WHO
DECIDED WHAT THEY WOULD LOOK AT
OR CLOSE INVESTIGATIONS AND YET
ANOTHER DETAIL IN THAT.
THE PROCESS HAD BEEN
TRADITIONALLY ONE WHERE WHEN
THESE REQUESTS WERE MADE BY
CONGRESS THEY WERE GIVEN ON
EITHER SIDE OF THE AISLE.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
ACCORDING TO JAMES COMER
CHANGED THE POLICY VERY
SPECIFICALLY SO THAT THE
TREASURY DEPARTMENT DIDN'T HAVE
TO GIVE THESE SUSPICIOUS
ACTIVITY REPORTS TO MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS ACROSS THE OTHER SIDE
OF THE AISLE.
IT REQUIRES A SUBPOENA.
MAXINE WATERS IS ACTUALLY THE
ONE WHO SPONSORED THE BILL TO
BRING IT BACK TO A NORMAL
PROCESS IRONICALLY SO.
IT HAS NOT BEEN VOTED ON AND
HASN'T PASSED.
RIGHT NOW THE PREROGATIVE IS IN
THE HANDS OF THE WHITE HOUSE
AND THEY ARE PREVENTING
REPUBLICANS FROM SEEING THESE
SUSPICIOUS ACTIVITY REPORTS AT
WHICH HUNTER HAD OVER 150.
>> Harris: WE CAN UNDERSTAND
WHY REPUBLICANS ARE LAYING INTO
THE F.B.I. CLAIMING IT IS
POLITICALLY BIASED.
YOU KNOW THERE ARE POLITICS
INSIDE OF ANY WHITE HOUSE AND
THERE ARE POLITICS INSIDE OF
THIS ONE.
IT IS NO EXCEPTION.
YESTERDAY AFTER THE POST REPORT
EVIDENCE THAT DISGRACED
EX-F.B.I. AGENT TIMOTHY
THIBAULT WAS THE POINT MAN FOR
FORMER HUNTER BIDEN BUSINESS
PARTNER TONY BOBULINSKI AND
NEVER FOLLOWED UP WITH HIM
ABOUT HIS BOMBSHELL
ALLEGATIONS, BOBULINSKI ALLEGED
ONE MONTH BEFORE THE 2020
ELECTION WAS JOE BIDEN WAS
INVOLVED WITH HIS SON HUNTER
AND HIS BROTHER JIM'S DEALING
WITH A CHINESE COMPANY.
F.B.I. CHIEF CHRIS WRAY MUST
EXPLAIN THE SUPPRESSION OF THE
HUNTER BIDEN INVESTIGATION.
PETE.
>> HE SURE NEEDS TO.
REMEMBER WHEN THE LEFT
CELEBRATED WHISTLEBLOWERS LIKE
LIEUTENANT COLONEL VINMAN?
HERE -- THE ONLY REASON WE KNOW
ABOUT THIS INDIVIDUAL, TIM
THIBAULT IS BECAUSE OF
WHISTLEBLOWERS.
HE IS A RAPID TRUMP HATER AND
BEEN IN CHARGE OF RUSSIA GATE
INVESTIGATIONS AND NOW THE
HUNTER BIDEN INVESTIGATION.
TONY BOBULINSKI SAID AFTER HE
SAT DOWN FOR FIVE HOURS WITH
THE F.B.I. YOUR FUTURE POINT
GUY IS TIM THIBAULT.
HE NEVER FOLLOWED UP AND CLOSED
THE INVESTIGATION WITHOUT THE
NORMAL PROCESS INSIDE THE F.B.I.
THIS AFTER THEY HAD HAD THE
LAPTOP SINCE DECEMBER OF 2019.
PLENTY OF TIME TO LOOK AT IT
AND VERIFY IT FOR BOBULINSKI
ABOUT WHO THE BIG GUY WAS.
THIS IS AN INSIDE COVER-UP JOB,
IT APPEARS, FROM THE F.B.I.
CERTAIN INDIVIDUALS WITH A LOT
OF POWER TO SHUT DOWN THE
INVESTIGATIONS THEY DON'T LIKE.
THANKFULLY THE "NEW YORK POST"
IS DOING THE WORK.
>> Harris: IT IS TIME TO DO
MORE QUESTION ASKING AND YES
THE "NEW YORK POST" CAN'T STAND
ALONE.
AS JOURNALISTS ACROSS THE BOARD
WE NEED TO BE ASKING QUESTIONS.
AS YOU CALLED THAT ONE PERSON,
A RABID TRUMP HATER THE
PRESIDENT IS BEING LOOKED AT AS
A RABID TRUMP VOTER HATER.
WHAT ARE THE PERKS FOR THE MAN
PERFORMING AT THE TOP VIA HIS
SON?
THAT'S A WORDY QUESTION.
YOUR PATRIOT AWARDS COMING UP
ARE SET FOR NOVEMBER 17th.
TICKETS ON SALE RIGHT NOW.
ALWAYS A GREAT OCCASION AND
ALWAYS WONDERFUL WHEN YOU ARE
PART OF IT.